welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down all of the
latest movies new game releases TV shows
and comic books with the second episode
of crisis on Infinite Earths now out for
release it's time to dive into the
latest entry and breakdown everything
that you need to know about the DC
crossover this episode focuses on the
aftermath of yesterday's huge death and
also throws some amazing cameos away
that come with a couple of curveballs
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here itself you haven't had a chance to
watch the episode yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of crisis on Infinite
Earths episode 2 okay so just a quick
recap on everything that's happened so
far a wave of destruction has ripped
across the entire multiverse and this
has caused the destruction of earth X
the Batman 1989 universe Batman 66 and
the Titans spin-off a 38 to came under
siege but after a bold sacrifice from
Oliver Queen on earth 1 the heroes were
able to evacuate most of the reality and
live to fight another day
however the events are playing out a lot
more severe than what was initially
predicted and with one of the greatest
heroes down the United Front is really
going to struggle going forward the
opening of the Batwoman episode centers
around the titular character Sara Lance
and Supergirl mourning the loss of arrow
this isn't a time for standstill oh and
we all know deep down that every actor
is Iying at what the CW shows will be
called going forward like the flash of
it the flash of is yeah yeah maybe not
we then jumped it at 74 where the
Harbinger walks out onto the Waverider
which is hilariously voiced by Lynn it's
not here she comes face to face with
Rory who's been living on the abandoned
ship since the retirement of the other
heroes of that reality she manages to
recruit him and take the Waverider as
well as it will be needed for what's to
come it said that the ship is going to
be paramount for what lies ahead and in
order to make it through the next fight
they will need to use the tech on board
the vessel much to the dismay of Sara
Lance who made a promise to never use
her in a crossover
again however as we know desperate times
call for desperate measures and with
Oliver's death being ahead of schedule
the monitor has realized that not all
that he is foreseen will happen as was
preordained the monitor has gone back to
the book of destiny and this has told
him that seven heroes are needed for the
upcoming battle these are known as
Paragons and the team already has the
paragon of Hope namely Supergirl and the
paragon of Destiny Sara Lance but who
the other two are is a mystery all the
monitor can gather from the book is that
there is a Batman from the future out
there who is the paragon of courage and
a Kryptonian who has lost more than any
mortal man could bear he will stand as
the paragon of truth and it's of the
utmost importance that they manage to
track him down
now unlike yesterday's episode I do feel
like this entry was a lot more balanced
and they weren't rushing through the
entire thing as fast as they could I
like that they allowed the show to
breathe a lot more and this made the
moments have a lot more weight to them
which yeah overall it just feels like a
step in the right direction over
yesterday's slightly rushed episode just
watching the heroes sharing a drink
planning out their next move and Cara
mourning the loss of her earth really
put some actual character development
into the show and makes it easier to
engage with iris has a really sweet
exchange with Barry and this kind of
gives us hope that because the monitor
was wrong about the death of arrow you
can also be wrong about the fate of the
flash Barry well-versed in the darker
side of the world reveals that he knows
about the Lazarus Pit and how it can
bring the dead back to the land of the
living Barry wants to use the
restorative powers of the pit to bring
all the back and hopefully change his
fate so if you watched yesterday's video
then you know that I said that Ollie's
death felt very underwhelming and I do
think that the events of the episode
will actually provide a lot more weight
for how the character goes out I think
all these eventual death will be a lot
more in line with the one that the
monitor saw which may be good for the DC
Universe but it's gonna be bad for Barry
as things will be playing out as
predicted Mia wants to bring Oliver back
no matter what but as we know when it
comes to the Lazarus pits they come with
a cost with the help of Constantine they
managed to locate one but saving all of
his soul is another matter entirely as
if things couldn't get worse we also
learn that the monitors saved Lex Luthor
I see is apparently by offer the task
head Quorra naturally is pretty upset
that there's billions upon billions dead
yet Lex Luthor is still alive Hey look
on the bright side Kara least he didn't
save the Kevin Spacey version on the
Waverider Lex steals the book of Destiny
and sets out across the multiverse to
kill every version of Superman
however yep you guessed it it was all
part of the plan in the end my man the
monitor is just playing
three-dimensional chess and knowing what
kind of person Lex was he revived him in
order to carry out this one task Cait
provides some comfort for Karl letting
her know that they still have a chance
to save the future of the multiverse and
together as she and Supergirl travel to
earth 99 to bring the Batman Paragon in
who is revealed to be played by none
other than Kevin Conroy
this was pretty much the one cameo out
of the entire series that I was looking
forward to the most
and it definitely didn't disappoint
anything Kevin Conroy does just feels
like The Dark Knight is he was always
meant to be and even as a twisted darker
and perhaps evil Batman he relishes the
role that he was born to play I
genuinely got goosebumps hearing his
voice echo throughout the halls of Wayne
Manor an actor just oozes presence
pretty much stealing the scene every
time he's on screen being Batman has
taken a huge toll on his body and
because of this Bruce now lives life
assisted by an exoskeleton we also
learned that on earth 99 at Kate died
five years earlier and naturally Bruce
is very wary about seeing her once more
across the multiverse Lois and Clark of
air 38 are trying to find a version of
Superman that can help them in the
coming on sort however as I mentioned
Lex is traveling from university
universe killing every Superman across
the vastness of all realities there's a
nice little nod to the death of superman
graphic novel and yeah this lets you
know that this time he isn't on the
heroes side this culminates on
Smallville and earth of 167 in which we
see the return of Tom Welling his
Superman iris Lois and Clark approached
him admiring the red and black
tablecloth that he's wearing and they
give him a warning that Lex is coming to
kill him there's also lip service paid
to Lex Luthor being president on this
world which was a big prediction that
was made in the Smallville series and
before they can provide Clark with any
information they're transported away by
Lex he reveals that he's there to kill
Clark and has kryptonite but when he
pulls it out it doesn't affect the X Man
of Steel as it's revealed that he gave
up his powers when settling down to have
a family he's still stronger than Lex
though who decides to leave after
realizing that this court can well he's
not gonna be any fun without his powers
this Superman isn't really interested in
fighting anymore
and nurse the group are gonna have to
find another version of the character
who wants to be more than a farmer now
going into this I was really excited for
this cameo and it was still a nice
little callback yeah I think Welling got
overshadowed quite a bit by Conroy who
we discover caused a reign of terror on
his earth after he finally snapped and
decided to start killing his rogues
gallery
I guess the Joker finally got to him and
he may have been the one that caused
Kate's death as Batman states something
turned him into a monster we see a
bloody Joker card a wilted plant from
poison ivy crack glasses from Superman
who it seems crippled him and a snow
globe - the figure from mr. freeze that
man has been a bad man but Kate has an
opportunity for him to right his wrongs
and save the universe now yesterday I
did say that I thought bat woman was
easily the worst part the crossover but
here she's not actually that bad I may
even go so far as to say she was okay no
no get what go broke they've changed me
must write ante sjw Twitter post saved
it anyway Lois Clark and iris go to
earth 96 and run into the Clark end of
the Superman Returns timeline on this
earth Clark has been promoted to editor
in chief of the Daily Planet and it's
revealed that he is the one who has
faced a great deal of loss in the wake
of an attack by the Joker this caused
the death of Lois Jimmy and Perry and
clock decides to join them in their plan
to save the multiverse later in the
episode there's also lip service paid to
Jason White who is Superman's son in
this universe
Clark dons the Superman costume from
Kingdom Come ready to join them and just
as it looks like things are going to be
okay Lex shows up and manipulates
Superman into going head-to-head with
the
from earth 38 it's a really great fight
that spans the skies of Metropolis and
it felt like one of the high points of
the crossover so far it's a little TV
ish effects wise but hey they still did
a pretty good job
Superman realizing he can't killed a 38
version decides to go for the ones that
Clark loves and this forces iris and
Louis is stealing a book of destiny from
Lex
using the emotion of love and all that
Superman has lost in order to bring him
back to the light this works and he
joins them also dropping a line about
going nuts and fighting himself which
yeah nice little callback to the good
old days of Superman on earth 18 the
group have managed to find the Lazarus
Pit which is revealed to be under God by
Jonah Hex want to know how he got those
scars well this episode will tell you
and both Sarah and Mia fight him cutting
his face in the process with hex out the
way they put Oliver in the pit who comes
back to life I guess this is comics and
people can't stay dead forever
but I was kind of expecting him to be
dead for a like at least one whole
episode you know make us feel the Holies
left make us want to be on their side
when they revived him because yet again
I think they kind of handled his passing
in the wrong way just my opinion but I
feel like it could have been pulled off
bear Oliver as expected comes back mad
and they tranquilize him however with
the antimatter that now exists in the
multiverse Constantine can conjure up
enough magic to save his soul and they
go ahead with an uncertain future
Batman goes full Batman V Superman drops
the line life only makes sense if he
force it to and he reveals that he
killed Superman Supergirl attempts to
take him down but Bruce still keeps
kryptonite on him which Dee powers her
Bruce tries to reason with Kay that the
world isn't worth saving and a to fight
with Bruce being electrocuted and the
struggle telling Kay that there is no
hope in his dying breath what I did like
about this death scene is that it was
similar to the Joker's one in Batman
Beyond and yeah it's nice that they at
least reflected on this in some ways on
the Waverider the group reunite and they
recap all of the events of the episode
slightly worse than me well well maybe
about the same level okay better than me
and they do a trial run to track down
the remaining
Paragons raise machine reveals that Kate
is actually the real paragon of courage
and that her actions against evil Bruce
have enabled her to become the true
symbol that they need Cora bonds with
Kaede and she states that when
everything is over she will use the book
of Destiny to restore a 38 this is said
to be extremely dangerous but yeah let's
face it they're definitely gonna be
doing that especially because she needs
somewhere to live going forward I think
this is the way that they will also
bring the Titans universe back as that
is scheduled for season 3 and with it
being wiped out we do need a method to
wreak on it K is of course cautious over
this and it looks like down the line she
may even be going head to head with
Supergirl as it's revealed that she took
the Kryptonite from bad boy Bruce and
now has it as a contingency plan should
things come to it crisis on Infinite
Earths is have caused very famous
because it contains the death of
Supergirl and who knows that
anti-monitor may even manage to get this
from Kate and use it to kill the
character I guess we will see but yeah
Korra is the paragon of hope and taking
her out would be a big loss for the
heroes whether that happens in our it
still looks like the team is coming
together nicely and it would be a shame
if someone showed up and ruined it oh so
for the finale the anti-monitor summons
the Harbinger and the two come face to
face ending the episode I did quite like
that the anti-monitor was played by the
same actor as the monitor as he is an
evil opposite to the character wishing
to wipe out the universe whilst the
monitor wishes to save it going forward
I think the fact that Constantine was
unable to bring all of her soul back
adds a lot more way to the spectre
theory that we dropped yesterday as
Oliver's body is pretty much just an
empty vessel now this will make a great
host for the spectre which I think the
monitor will potentially call upon to
inhabit it in the original graphic novel
that the spectre was the one that
actually United the heroes together
after they managed to defeat the
anti-monitor and he decided to travel
back in time to stop the multiverse from
ever being created can definitely see
this being a big part of the show and
who knows the plan may start to fall in
place for the next episode
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the crossover and what you
want to see in the next entry comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown and recap of yesterday's
episode which would be linked at the end
you go over everything you need to know
about it
and give our theories for the future so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel amour and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on crisis in the comment
section below the one that's gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of December
and the set will be shipped up from then
- ever gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace
you